As the climate crisis worsens,
too many people are swinging
from denial straight to despair.
But we should not lose hope.
Humanity has enormous resources
under its command,
and by applying them wisely,
we can still prevent ecological cataclysm.
Let's talk numbers.
What would it cost to prevent
catastrophic climate change?
Would we have to commit
50 percent of our total budget?
Thirty percent?
Ten percent?
Naturally enough, no one knows for sure.
My team and I have spent weeks
poring over various reports
and academic papers
living in a cloud of numbers.
But while the models behind the numbers
are dizzyingly complex,
the bottom line should cheer us up.
Most experts converge
on the number two percent.
If humanity increases our annual
investment in clean technologies
and infrastructure by around
two percent of global GDP,
that should be enough to prevent
catastrophic climate change.
If you want to see how experts
got to that number,
you're welcome to visit
the Sapienship website.
We can, of course, argue endlessly
about the exact number,
tweaking the models this way and that way.
But we should look at the big picture.
The crucial news is that the price tag
of preventing the apocalypse
is in the low single digits
of annual global GDP.
Even the more pessimistic models
generally estimate it
at below five percent.
And most models say it requires investing
only an additional two percent
of global GDP in the right places.
And note the word investing.
We are not talking
about burning piles of banknotes
in some huge sacrifice
to the spirits of the Earth.
We are talking about making investments
in new technologies and infrastructure,
such as advanced batteries
or other technologies
to store solar energy
and updated power grids to distribute it.
These investments will create lots
of new jobs and economic opportunities
and are likely to be economically
profitable in the long run,
in part by reducing
health care expenditures
and saving millions of people
from sickness caused by air pollution.
In addition, since oil and gas often prop
up autocratic and militaristic regimes,
reducing our dependence on fossil fuels
will be a huge boon
to democracy and to peace.
All this can be translated
into a concrete political plan of action.
We have learned in recent years
to define our goal in terms of one number:
1.5 degrees Celsius.
We can define the means to do this
with another number: two percent.
Increased investment in clean
technologies and infrastructure
by two percentage points of global GDP,
above 2020 levels.
Of course, unlike the 1.5 Celsius figure,
which is a scientifically
robust threshold,
the two-percent figure represents
only a rough guesstimate.
It should be understood
as a ballpark figure
that can help to frame
the kind of political project
humanity requires.
It tells us that preventing
catastrophic climate change
is a totally feasible project,
even though it would obviously
cost a lot of money.
Since global GDP in 2020
was about 85 trillion US dollars,
we are talking about a number
around 1.7 trillion US dollars.
But that's still just two percent.
This means that to save the environment,
we don't need to completely
derail the economy
or to abandon the achievements
of modern civilization.
We just need to get our priorities right.
Committing two percent
of annual global GDP
is far from the whole story, of course.
It won't solve all
our ecological problems,
such as oceans brimming with plastic
or the continued loss of biodiversity.
And even to prevent
catastrophic climate change
we'll need to make sure that the funds
are invested in the right places
and that the new investments don't cause
their own negative
ecological or social fallout.
We will also need to change
some of our behaviors
and ways of thinking
from what we eat to how we travel.
None of that will be easy.
But that's exactly
why we have politicians.
Their job is to deal with the hard stuff.
And politicians are actually very skilled
at shifting two percent of resources
from here to there.
It's what they do all the time.
The difference between
the policies of right wing
and left wing parties
often amounts to a few
percentage points of GDP.
When faced by a major crisis,
politicians swiftly shift
far more resources to fight it.
For example, in 1945,
the US spent about 36 percent of its GDP
on winning the Second World War.
During the 2008-2009 financial crisis,
the US government spent
about 3.5 percent of GDP
to save financial institutions
that were deemed "too big to fail."
Maybe humankind should also treat
the Amazon rainforest
as too big to fail.
Let's try a thought experiment.
Given the current price of cleared
rainforest land in South America
and the size of the Amazon rainforest,
buying the [whole] of it in order
to protect local forests,
biodiversity and human communities
from destructive business interests
would cost about 800 billion dollars,
or a one-off payment
of less than one percent of global GDP.
In just the first nine months of 2020,
governments around the world
announced stimulus measures
worth nearly 14 percent of global GDP
to deal with the COVID-19 pandemic.
If citizens pressed them hard enough,
politicians can do the same
to deal with the ecological crisis.
So can investment banks and pension funds.
Pension funds hold
over 56 trillion US dollars.
What's the point of having a pension
if you don't have a future?
At present,
most businesses and governments
are unwilling to make
the additional two-percent investment
necessary to prevent
catastrophic climate change.
Where does that money go instead?
Well, every two years,
approximately 2.4 percent of global GDP
is spent on food that goes to waste.
Governments also spend
about 500 billion US dollars annually
on -- wait for it --
direct subsidies for fossil fuels.
That means that every 3.5 years
governments write a nice fat check
for an amount equivalent to two percent
of annual global GDP
and gift it to the fossil fuel industry.
And it gets worse when you factor in
the social and environmental costs
that the fossil fuel industry causes
but isn't asked to pay for,
the value of these subsidies
actually reaches a staggering
seven percent of annual global GDP.
Now consider tax evasion.
It's estimated that the money hidden
by the wealthy in tax havens
is worth around 10 percent of global GDP.
Every year,
another 1.4 trillion dollars in profits
is stashed offshore by corporations,
which is equal to 1.6 percent
of global GDP.
To prevent the apocalypse,
we'll probably need to impose
some new taxes.
But why not start
with collecting the old ones?
Such examples can be multiplied.
But you get the picture.
The money is there.
Of course, collecting taxes,
stopping food wastage
and slashing subsidies
is easier said than done,
especially when faced by some
of the most powerful lobbies in the world.
But it doesn't require a miracle.
It just requires determined organization.
So we shouldn't succumb to defeatism.
Whenever someone says,
"It's too late, the apocalypse is here,"
reply, "Nah, we can stop it
with just two percent."
And when COP 27 convenes
in Egypt in November 2022,
we should tell the attending leaders
that it's not enough to make
vague future pledges
about 1.5 degrees Celsius.
We want them to take out their pens
and sign a check
for two percent of annual global GDP.
Thank you.